[Music]
one of the males on my course said to me
oh you're going to have sex tonight
and i kind of said
well how do you know that
and
he said oh because i'm stronger than you
almost two-thirds of women in the
british armed forces have experienced
bullying discrimination or harassment
he just went around the club and then
turned into a car park
parked up
and then proceeded to get his penis up
my eyes shut down at
a fear of backlash and a culture of
impunity
means that few report their experiences
i went
for a shower in the morning and i was
raped
fondled
pinned against the wall
a gagging order prevents serving
personnel from talking to the media
but the economist has spoken to former
service women
some are still too scared to speak
publicly
their experiences span 50 years
and reveal the extent of the problem and
why it's so hard to change
so i joined the royal air force 10 days
after my 17th birthday
[Music]
[Applause]
my father was a real marine my
grandfather was a royal marine
and i wanted to escape run away have an
adventure
and join the military and be just as
tough as my dad
in 2001 three years after joining the
raf
rebecca was posted to the falkland
islands where she kept a video diary
she was sent to a remote radar site
where there were 28 men
she was the only woman
i flew in on a helicopter and was
greeted by
a line of a lineup of men on the
helipads
mooning me in
and to be greeted by that set of
president really for what was to come
this is uh
this is tigger
that night i was subjected to an
initiation ceremony and that was just
vile and brutal
some of the servicemen were naked with
rubber gloves on their genitals and
their head
and they
were encouraging me to
lather them with like a soapy
liquid
and there were pictures that were taken
with them kind of
manhandling me and um
yeah it was it was awful
that kind of pack mentality was hugely
intimidating especially being the only
woman
i just
instinctively knew something was wrong
and disturbing yet i felt scared
and ashamed of
what might happen if i spoke out about
it
there is something about i think the
military way of life that can create
conditions which make it
more likely that sexual harassment may
occur more likely that a sexual assault
may occur
emma norton is a lawyer who represents
women who have been sexually assaulted
in the military
they've got to tolerate standards of
behaviour that in any other walk of life
they absolutely wouldn't tolerate but
they've got to do that in order to fit
in
the behaviour is not just historic
lucy was in the raf just a few years ago
she's no longer serving but is still too
frightened of repercussions to reveal
her identity
when i joined up i think there was a
real push to employ
women to get women in
the raf but actually there wasn't a lot
of understanding or any
real
inclusivity for women
the instructor chose to give me and
another female kind of sexualized
nicknames
at the time i went along with it and
then reflecting back on it kind of
realized well that didn't happen to the
men
in 2021 a parliamentary inquiry into the
british military found that more than
one in 10 women had experienced sexual
harassment in the past
year there was a male on my course who
just followed me everywhere
i would be sat
kind of in a common area and
he would be stood
in front of me with like his legs
touching mine
or he'll touch my hair
and then there was a
specific point where he said to me
would you mind if i raped you
for some women the abuse went further
than harassment
jean joined the forces in the 1970s
her first experience of sexual assault
was during her army medical
i was told by the doctor
to strip naked
and he told me to stand in front of him
and to stand with my legs astride
and he leaned forward and inserted two
ungloved fingers into my vagina
um
making the comment that it's just to see
if you're normal inside
i've got this flashback of me looking at
myself
with it happening and
just
feeling really confused and
just disgusted really but also at the
same time thinking he's a doctor
women were really regarded as
sort of secondary to male soldiers
we were considered in some ways sexual
commodities
jean says she continued to be assaulted
and harassed during her three and a half
years in the army
then she was told that she was going to
be discharged for being gay
which was illegal in the british armed
forces until 2000
there was a summer ball on and this
officer male officer
persuaded me to go outside with him and
he kept wanting me to give him all sex
and um
i just didn't want to do it and
um he kept insisting and saying like
i'll prove you're not gay
in the end i i sort of felt like i had
to do it
jean like many service women was too
frightened to report what happened to
her
the parliamentary survey in 2021 found
that 60 percent did not report their
experiences of bullying harassment or
discrimination
and of those who did more than a third
said their complaints were handled
extremely poorly
when i complained it was really all over
the place it was a really difficult
process because the system isn't set up
for those kinds of complaints at one
moment i was told one thing and the next
i was told another
just lost complete faith in that system
in some cases
women have found that rather than
investigate senior officers have tried
to silence them
i made a complaint
to to a senior member of the
of the squad and they flew a commanding
officer up from the main mountain he
insisted on having
the meeting the chat with me
in my bedroom
it was you're the troublemaker let's
have a chat with you in your bedroom and
a little
kind of telling off about
you want to be careful
if you want to leave the raf with a good
report
this is my
i kept this this is where i would file
all my appraisals
i was invited to comment
and i said i have thoroughly enjoyed my
tour
there's no mention of the complaint or
anything within the appraisal
it's a
shining
report
it's
it's unbelievable i mean it's it's not
unbelievable this is what happens
there's no acknowledgement of it but
then i was
pushed into a corner to stay in order to
get this shining piece of paper which is
really not useful to me at all and i
never was
but those in the upper ranks may have
gone further than trying to suppress
complaints
some claim they have also tried to cover
up serious sexual crimes
graham house served in the raf for 30
years
he was a wing commander when an
allegation of rape was made against one
of the instructors serving on his base
by a 13 year old cadet
i received a call from a lady who said
her daughter had been a cadet on my unit
a few weeks before
and whilst on my unit she'd been raped
by her instructor and she wanted to know
what i was going to do about that
the expectation and the obligation is
i'm going to do something about that
what i didn't realize is my chain of
command thought differently they were
more concerned about the reputational
impact of that allegation
and i was incentivized therefore to be
silent about it to not initiate an
investigation
effectively to conceal it and pass the
problem to the mother
and make it her challenge to address it
even though it happened on our unit i
ended up in a point of conflict with my
chain of command because i disagreed
with what i was being told to do
i broke rank i broke jurisdiction i took
the issue to the civil police
that led to an inquiry a court case a
conviction and the imprisonment of the
royal air force instructor
and a few weeks later i was then removed
sacked from my job
for graham to break rank and go to the
civilian courts was highly controversial
because the expectation is that rape
cases are handled by the armed forces
themselves
the military police carry out
investigations
and cases are tried at court-martial
although some say it is hard to compare
the two systems
in civilian courts around 60 of rape
cases end in a conviction at
court-martial it's closer to 10
far far better
to send those difficult cases which even
in the civilian system are hard to get a
conviction for but give them the best
possible chance of success and put them
in a place where there is a great deal
more experience in dealing with and
supporting victims particularly victims
of sexual crime because there's a very
very little experience of that
inside the military and you see victims
being actively harmed
by some of the
actions that are being undertaken around
them
a coroner calls on the mod to review its
care of vulnerable soldiers after the
suicide of a 30 year old corporal
one case in particular laid bare the
catastrophic effects of the military's
handling of serious sexual offences
the coroner said corporal element was
subject to bullying after being
transferred to the bullford army base in
wiltshire following allegations she'd
been raped by two colleagues in germany
corporal anne-marie element was in the
royal military police
in 2009 she alleged that she'd been
raped by two of her colleagues
and claimed she'd been subjected to very
serious bullying
almost two years later she took her own
life
the inquest into her death uncovered a
whole range of very very serious
problems many of them systemic they
included complete failures to provide
her with care in view of the trauma that
she had suffered
what's really really sad and awful about
it is that those systemic failures were
only revealed because she died
if she had just about survived if she
decided not to take her own life
those failings won't be revealed
following corporal element's death a new
code of practice was put in place for
commanding officers to follow when
serious crimes are reported to them it
includes basic measures such as
separating the victim and the accused
whilst on duty it's a good policy the
question is is it being applied and then
in our experience it's absolutely not
the ministry of defence also set up an
ombudsman to handle complaints
it was to this ombudsman that lucy
submitted her formal complaint
it was upheld
but for lucy this wasn't enough to heal
the suffering she'd endured
and i got to the point where i was
suicidal
and i just remember being in the kitchen
i had this knife in my hand
all i wanted to do
was squeeze it
and when we talk about trauma
it is so difficult
to put what we're going through into
words and that in itself holds
the system back
for many of the women the psychological
pain of their experiences still affects
them today
i just started drinking a lot i lost my
job
and then
just everything spiraled from then
really
i couldn't even have a relationship with
anyone because i just
i don't know i just couldn't cope with
the physical side of things
because i was just um too damaged inside
and i just sort of feel that i'm not
meant to be this person i am today
[Music]
those who have tried to protect the
vulnerable have found themselves cast
out into the cold
i was squashed
punished
silenced
vilified discredited because i
questioned the integrity of my chain of
command if it could do that to me as a
commanding officer with that background
it can do it to anyone and i've realized
it will do it to anyone
graham house now campaigns for an
independent defense authority to oversee
complaints about the armed forces rather
than the military investigating itself
we put the allegations in this film to
the ministry of defence and it responded
the armed forces take any allegation of
rape or sexual assault very seriously
and where complaints were made these
historic incidents would have been
thoroughly investigated and appropriate
action taken
serving in the armed forces today is a
very different experience to how it was
20 years ago but we continue to make
important changes to stamp out all
unacceptable behaviors
that's where i think you see the real
damage
in 2021 graham house and emma norton
gave evidence to a parliamentary inquiry
you do have a particular difficulty in
the armed forces because women are in a
very stark minority there which also
heard testimonies of over 4 000 female
veterans and service women
[Music]
the gagging order which prevents current
serving personnel from speaking freely
was lifted
the committee made a number of
recommendations
including transferring rape and sexual
assault cases to the civilian court
system
and ensuring that complaints related to
sexual offences are not handled by the
complainants commanding officer
at the end of 2021 the government
responded to these proposals with what
it has described as a
comprehensive set of measures to improve
the experience of women in the armed
forces
which includes
strengthening levers available to
dismiss or discharge those who are found
to have committed sexual offences or
unacceptable sexual behavior
and ensuring
investigations to be conducted outside
of the single service chain of command
but sexual offence cases can still be
handled by the military justice system
it is really important to acknowledge
that there have been important
improvements and changes and that the
armed forces today is not the same as it
was five years ago 10 years ago 20 years
ago but what you're not seeing
is fundamental change and the kinds of
reforms that are being proposed they're
not
going to affect operational
effectiveness they're not going to
explode the chain of command
how many reviews will there have been
from this from my time to now
women are just their life lives have
been ruined and people are
lives aren't just being ruined i mean
some people are losing their lives
there is no system set up to challenge
systemic issues there is no system
set up to challenge the culture
and i was told things like oh well we
can't change hearts and minds
when actually
that's exactly what's needed
[Music]
i don't know what's going to change
because here we are in 2021 and i'm
having the same conversations and i'm
still so affected by it nothing will
change until we
we get louder and explode open
to read more of our coverage and for a
list of organizations that can help
please click on the link
thank you for watching and don't forget
to subscribe